i think in the 21st century a lot of
people are
too
dunya centric
cars phones
technology
allah created us from this earth
it says in the quran from it we create
you and to it you'll return and from it
you will be resurrected against
[Music]
[Music]
so where are we headed bro what's the
first step
you can't come to dubai without saying
hello to the desert bro
let's get it
let's do it
bro so when there's no traffic how long
does it take to go to the desert
from here like 45 30 35 45 depends how
many speed tickets you want to take it's
called fossil rock
mix between mountain and desert
you can see the
the these are the bubbies these are the
arabian oranges you see
they're called puppies
what are what are they
the big oranges or the little ones
actually we are in charge right sorry
charger is a different yeah
at the camera and how it was created
okay so i'll just
i will drive a little
let's be bit something the guys come
with their little motorcycles
because
it's even at night sometimes you don't
know
right
inshallah
a desert flower look at that
proper purple
anyhow
that's true look at this
[Music]
bro this is like therapy
who needs a psychiatrist bro
after the buzz or whatever it is to
finish in dubai just drive back and stop
here
right here
i think in the 21st century a lot of
people are
too
dunya centric
and what do you mean by dunya centric
like everything is about the world life
cars phones
technology
so
allah created us from this earth
he says in the quran from it we create
you and to it you'll return and from it
you will be resurrected against man
right
so there's a connection
in even our the way our body is the
carbon chain and all that
and
it's we're connected to the earth
so
when you go in nature and you walk you
put your feet in sand
there's
something happens i think your body you
gotta
spiritually physically
you have to experience it you know
most people live in the city most people
don't even see a sunset don't even look
at the sky
when
you have to unplug
like if you listen there's no sound
there's no other than the wind you know
when you go to like a forest you see a
lot of birds chirping a lot of insects a
lot of things that distract you oh look
at that tree
when you come to the desert
just a very uniform type of feeling you
know just kind of look
that's why it's fun most of the prophets
came from desert this area
i don't know if there's a connection to
that but there's you feel different
you
you're more clear when you're in the
desert what advice do you have for a
brother or sister that lives in like a
city and they don't have places like
this to isolate everyone's got a park or
somewhere if you drive an hour like do
it on a regular basis at least once a
month you have to unplug
you owe it to yourself unplug
go whatever forest
park
lake mountains right a lot of them just
you need that you need that leave your
phone away just
just chill
let it be just a few hours even
even that is is good enough
and just sit and make tada
like
throughout
the quran you see
allah always
directs the stories
look at this creation look at that look
at the mountains you can see look at
this
there's always something with the
creation
to remind you of the creator
[Music]
it's you know people call it like uh
pondering or reflecting or reflecting
it's very deep
it's it's it's not meditation it's not
meditation meditation is supposed to be
absent
here you're fully present the system
always
people think it's just another religion
right no i don't want to hear it's
christianity
it's not like that
it's in the quran it doesn't just
believe just believe allah is indicating
you and it's not like
esoteric type of knowledge it's only you
select people can understand it's like
for everyone everyone and all you need
to do is just look around and analyze
and when you think about these things
you come up to these
these realizations like wait a second i
can't be
that things just happen
by chance okay not
which leads me to an exercise where how
did it become
who made it happen
it's very logical i mean or rational at
least right yeah like wait a second how
how did this happen okay so one leads to
another
but
and that's why you know they say that
farmers are
usually
still believers wherever they are they
still because they're so tight to the
earth right
it's all clear raised
from the caves you know you go on the
mountain up high
yeah
i come i'll meet you
1200 about 300 bucks
for all that yeah because it's like
so if the if the bubble goes too fast
then it's not good the bubble goes slow
mother to her
[Music]
you know when this was uh when this was
built
two years ago
exactly okay
[Music]
uh
you gotta get in there
he says you have to drink it before
work or your mo your brain is gonna go
far bro it's gonna be messed up
so it gives you strength right
there's a song
down it's my place
no it's fine huh
they're very
crazy
what's your favorite part about dubai
favorite part about dubai no the desert
no no the city we know we we know you
like the desert bro the city
the city yeah
the water why
we created everything from water
is
mashallah
okay
[Music]
yo what's your favorite meal here bro
pizza i like to eat the lipstick and
beat the cookie and banana banana
[Music]
bro
this is a
undisclosed location right now where we
are
no one can find out right yeah this is
called the secret recording studio
number 69
right here
in the disbelievers they have side
things they have a work wife they have
the the chick he texts they have the
actual wife they have the girlfriend
the the
one he probably hires there's so many
yeah
and in islam we have wives now a lot of
people think that having multiple wives
is the same as having multiple
girlfriends or sidekicks
mashallah see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]